[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Gupta vpgm for infrastructure at Google
Cloud
the roles of Enterprise Architects and
developers are evolving
not only do you have to keep the lights
on you are expected to stay on top of
the ever-changing trends and
technologies that create business value
and you have to do all of this while
lowering costs and improving performance
so it infrastructure runs quickly and
smoothly
Your Role is critical to a successful
transformation with Google Cloud you can
innovate faster and more easily while
optimizing costs we know organizations
like yours still have a lot of
infrastructure to migrate and we are
committed to helping you migrate more
securely and efficiently Global
customers and local Partners like Palo
Alto Networks h m and Major League
Baseball rely on us to deliver scalable
High performing highly available Cloud
infrastructure and services AI is in our
DNA
from AI powered search to YouTube
recommendation engines and Google
Assistant Cloud TPU V4 delivers industry
leading ml training performance and
scale with six terabits per second
interconnect you can run large-scale
training workloads up to 80 faster and
up to 50 cheaper compared to
Alternatives we're also announcing new
A2 Ultra gpus built on nvidia's a100 80
gig gpus with high speed memory today we
are announcing a new industry Consortium
the open xla project that will unite an
ecosystem of leading machine learning
compiler Technologies and accelerate and
simplify machine learning Innovation
these open source AI contributions
enable you to take your AI idea and turn
it into reality easily and at low cost
Cloud armor is another security
innovation that provides Advanced ml
powered DDOS and wav protection for web
apps services and apis
it has prevented some of the largest
DDOS attacks on the planet with zero
impact to customers recently the largest
https attack was staged against a cloud
armor customer
it was 76 percent larger than anything
previously reported the equivalent of
Wikipedia's daily requests in 10 seconds
and the customer experience no impact
and for regulated Industries with
stringent and Country specific
requirements we offer controls to meet
your digital Pharmacy objectives since
transformation takes different forms for
different Industries we partner with
customers to build industry-leading
innovative solutions in media and
entertainment we provide solutions to
customers like you next with streaming
built on the same Google infrastructure
we've tested and tuned to serve
YouTube's two billion users globally
to get a better picture of how our media
and entertainment industry customers
innovate with Google Cloud I'm proud to
introduce senior vice president
technical infrastructure of Major League
Baseball Truman boys
[Music]
[Applause]
Major League Baseball's technology
mission is to connect with our fans our
infrastructure team has historically
maintained applications on-prem and now
we have unlimited compute from the
public cloud and this allowed us to shut
down four data centers modernize all of
our infrastructure and to spin things up
rapidly
and in the off season we scale it back
Google's Cloud helps us to understand
the entire fan journey and artificial
intelligence allows us to derive a
better connection to them we're able to
have personalized content with that fan
it gets richer over time as we learn
more about them
working with Google we're preserving the
history of baseball going back into the
1940s and we're able to make highlights
available to our fans Google Cloud hosts
all of these video clips for us and now
we have an opportunity to enrich this
format beyond what it is today
we're looking to modernize the entire
platform that we have and move into
delivery through media CDN
Major League Baseball and Google Cloud
are connecting with our fans so that
experience is happening in venue as well
as a digital experience and we're not
getting out of the park
thank you so much Truman it is amazing
to see how MLB is innovating for The Fan
Experience leveraging Google
Technologies like AI media CDN and the
reliability and elasticity of our Global
infrastructure
we've shared a number of ways in which
we've built our infrastructure to enable
transformation
but we also continue to build Solutions
and products tuned to support your top
workloads and data applications
and we've optimized these for both
performance and cost
one example of this is Google Cloud
VMware engine
VMware engine is a fully managed native
Google service that helps you lift and
shift your VMware applications to Google
Cloud faster and easier
we are the first external provider to
support vmware's Cloud Universal program
which makes it easier for you to migrate
to the cloud
and with built-in point-and-click
migration tools and our instant
provisioning feature you can get
workloads running in your private cloud
in less than one hour we are continuing
to scale VMware engine by increasing
support from 64 to 96 nodes per private
Cloud all with four lines of
availability in a single site and a
dedicated 100 gigabit per second Network
this provides high performance and
reliability for your most demanding
production workloads another example of
workload optimization is a recently
announced Google Cloud
high performance Computing toolkit HPC
toolkit is an open source tool from
Google that helps you quickly and easily
create repeatable TurnKey HPC clusters
next I'm really excited to announce
c3vms
it is the first VM on the market to
feature the latest generation of Intel
Sapphire Rapids processors and is built
on new Intel Google co-designed
infrastructure processing units or ipus
all of this together means
differentiated performance security
isolation and flexibility
C3 is the first VM in our Fleet with 200
gigabits per second low latency
networking to support a variety of
workloads such as data processing web
serving and high throughput HPC
workloads moving on to another product
built to Leverage The ipu Google cloud
hyperdesk is the next generation of
block storage which will be available on
both compute engine and gke
we are decoupling block storage
performance from the VM allowing you to
tune your storage performance to your
workload needs our new flexible
committed use discounts or Flex Cuts can
make it easier to save and manage costs
across teams by giving you region and VM
family flexibility with autoclass
customers like redvis are reducing
storage costs and achieving Better Price
predictability in a simple way
it automatically transitions objects to
cooler storage based on the last time
they were accessed and transitions to
standard storage upon access our new
migration Center can reduce complexity
time and cost
by providing key capabilities in
migrating and modernizing to Virtual
machines containers or serverless
Computing dual run lets you replicate
your Mainframe workload in Google cloud
and run the two environments in parallel
this allows you to confirm successful
operations in Google Cloud
before your cutover which can massively
reduce risk
managed instance groups or migs with
auto scaling use application metrics to
radically simplify and improve
operational efficiency allowing you to
scale in and out without manual
intervention
and with the power of Google's ml
Mexican predictably scale in and out
based on historical data
these three defining pillars for Google
Cloud infrastructure
transformative
optimized and easy
are the key tenets behind our
intentional engineering efforts this is
why so many customers trust Google Cloud
and what helps to power such Innovation
across the industry
I invite you to try Google cloud and our
Innovative new releases we look forward
to delighting you
thank you
[Music]